what about some of the other
popular candidates what do you think
about AOC
I don't know if she self-identifies as a
socialist or not she does self-identify
as a as a Democratic Socialist
I think she was a very inspiring figure
for for a lot of um people she was kind
of out of this Bernie wave of the first
set of Bernie candidates in 2018 that
identified with him instead of the
democratic party establishment
I think that
she's still developing as a politician
it's very difficult when you're in a
deep blue District
and
when
you don't often have to worry about
re-election or talk to but modulate your
rhetoric to win over swing voters in
your District but then you're
immediately a national and cultural
figure
so AOC basically goes from her views
which are compelling and in my mind a
lot of her programmatic views are
compelling wins her district and then
has her own rhetoric which to me
compared to Bernie owes itself more
to the academic left and the way that a
lot of the left has learned to talk I
don't mean academic sense that she's
like a Marxist or whatever else but
academic and the way that
she may be
using at times like confusing language
to convey basic points when she gets
into like
the like language of intersectionality
and whatever else especially in the
context of cultural issues and stuff
like that exactly instead of just the
plain spoken burning like yeah
discrimination is is wrong if you ask me
about a cultural issue I'll come down to
the same side as AOC I'm sure you know
nine plus tens out of uh times out of
ten but I'll try to root it into just
basic like yeah treat people with
respect you know and they'll treat you
with respect and that's the way we
should govern our Civics fear you know
and we don't need to talk about about
intersectionality to to I think get that
but so there's that rhetoric
but she's not just regular
congressperson in a deep blue District
she's also a national and international
cultural and political figure so she's
now a spokesperson because of larger
like a media event of her surprising
upset election and her being you know
young and like being really connected to
this post-burny moment
and I think amid these constant one
attacks on her from the right and also
this media attention and this notoriety
she hasn't really modulated or adjusted
her audience her rhetoric and how do you
win over someone who
really hates a lot of your ideas but
might actually believe in some of your
policies and
um I think she's been
um ineffective quite frankly in the last
year making that transition whereas I
think other politicians who are not so
far left
um who don't identify socialists but
let's say a John Federman has managed to
become more effective and I don't think
it's a question of character or whatever
else and I like AOC so I don't want to
put it so harshly but I think a lot of
it has to do with her being a congress
person in a deep blue district and
fetterman being running for Statewide
office in a you know quote-unquote
purple State
um but at her best at her best she does
it but it's like glimmers you okay it's
kind of like um I don't know what's what
sport are you biggest fan of I'll give
you a sports analogy I like the end of I
mean uh NFL is up there soccer is up
there but probably UFC okay well I can't
give you a good analogy for any of those
but it's like a raw Prospect like you
know someone who who shows glimmers of
hope so they were drafted really high
and then they Bounce from Team to team
and you're like I'm clinging onto my see
a stock but um but I think that
that she needs to be self-critical
enough and her team needs to be
self-critical enough to know the goal is
not merely to be a national cultural
figure and win a re-election near deep
blue District the goal has to be to
become truly a national political figure
which will require changes
a unifier an inspiring figure about the
ideas that she represents definitely and
and she has other things against her
like I'm obviously class focused but
there's no denying I think that some of
the hostility to her is like sexism you
know it's rooted in I think people
um wanting to see her fail or whatever
else but that's only some of it you know
I think some of it otherwise is her
struggling to relate to people who don't
have a lot of her her you know starting
points as far as moral and ethical
beliefs
yeah but she's actually great at
flourishing in all the all the attacks
she's getting she's she's doing a good
job with that and a lot of those attacks
will break me if I'm being honest yes
that's that's the amount of fire she's
under
um but you don't want that to become a
drug to where you just get good at being
a national figure that's constantly in
the fights and are using that for
attention so on you still want to be the
unifier and that's a tricky tricky
switch do you think there's a chance
there's a world in which she's able to
modulate it enough to be a unifier and
run for president
and when I think she's very far away
from being able to do that
I think that
[Music]
um
even other politicians that are also
polarizing within the squad in terms of
what they say their ideas whatever else
are very effective communicators like
Johan Omar and others
um
I think I think AOC I mean that's my
hope right my hope is that someone like
AOC
um could uh the last year plus have not
has not been extremely promising you
know in my in my mind in part because
she's become or she's continued to
position herself as a lightning rod
cultural
figure
whereas I think a national political
figure needs to pick their spots and
also pick their moment for changing
their their rhetoric and adjusting to
Their audience and I think she does it
in certain environments but that needs
to be your National message when you're
out there
um you need to be speaking towards the
not already
converted and I think Bernie does that
Bernie strips his politics down to the
basics
so I agree with you spiritually but I
also we also have an example of Donald
Trump winning the presidency
isn't some
isn't some of the game of politics
that's separate from the policy
being able to engage in rhetoric that's
that leads to outrage and then walking
through that fire with Grace
first of all I think Trump was is kind
of a unique personality in American
history so it's hard to to
compare anyone to to Trump but don't you
think AOC is comparable in terms of the
uniqueness
in the political system we're in or no
it's much more of a Firebrand
anti-establishment Force
um
in that and I mean this negatively for
what it's worth because I I don't
disagree with Trump but he was willing
to set fire to the Republican
um uh establishment right uh he was able
to self-fund you know largely his
campaign and he already was a media
figure without them uh AOC has been much
more cautious for the Democratic party
establishment in part because she's not
trying to run a national political
campaign right now for the outside like
a five percent chance to be president
let me set fire to everything she's
trying to help people and help her
constituents through the game of getting
committee appointments and you know
getting wins in the margins and I think
that's understandable for what it's
worth but in the process I think
what's the difference between AOC and a
progressive Democrat during 2016 it used
to be pretty easy to say the difference
between the Bernie Kratz and a
progressive Democrat right because we
were establishing our own outside third
force in American politics
were you know you could knock on the
door of a lot of people who would end up
voting for Trump and they would say oh I
have a lot of respect for for Bernie or
whatever they're still gonna not vote
for him but he wasn't considered part of
the democratic party milieu
um I think now with AOC there's a much
closer Association of AOC in our
policies with ordinary
Democrats where she needs to draw
stronger distinctions she does need to
do it like um Trump did with just man I
forgot all of them though I found some
of them amusing in the moment like all
his nicknames about a lion Ted Cruz and
then the rest you know
um but I do feel like she needs to um
yeah differentiate herself a bit more
but then also just keep her language
simple
Trump
was more complex than Bernie
um in his his literal language but he
was repetitive and there was kind of a
rhythm and a Cadence to Trump's speech I
think AOC needs to like Bernie reduce
her rhetoric down to a couple key lines
and signatures and focus her politics
not on 20 issues but on three or four
most important issues and have that
message discipline
Bernie will do an interview with you and
he'll write down
hope you do interview Bernie
um but he'll write down like five things
and I yeah I'm only gonna talk about
these five things yeah ask me about this
okay I'm talking about these five things
so that's a message discipline that
Bernie has been exemplary on yeah yeah
sure so but I think that's learned that
could be developed I think she could
develop it listen I hope I'm answering a
question I think not the way I should
answer it being someone you know
broadcasting to
um to people on the on the left and and
and and and and you know elsewhere
um I hope AOC goes in that direction I
just think that she has a lot going
against her just because she's already a
national figure
and choosing a deeper blue District but
but we need to root our politics then in
Working Class People and a lot of
districts that I don't know the the type
of kitchen table conversations are I
hate that cliche but I just used it but
a lot of these these conversations are
just different in their tone and Cadence
and it's not just a question of I you
know fetterman or Tim Ryan in Ohio and
kind of just white working class voters
I mean working class voters of any race
um there's their day-to-day needs and
the day-to-day things they want to talk
about is just at a different plane than
you know uh a Met Gala cultural
statement
yeah I mean it's clear that your respect
and lover and and would like to see uh
different ways I mean she's young so the
different trajectories that she could
develop that would ultimately uh make
her a good candidate I'm just looking
odds here
for and I disagree with them I'm buying
AOC stock here given these odds so uh in
terms of democratic who's going to win
the 2024 election so that includes
running and winning uh on the Democrat
side is 18 chance for Biden seven
percent chance for Kamala Harris Gavin
Newsom at six percent Michelle Obama at
uh three percent Hillary Clinton at two
percent and AOC at 1.5 percent and then
Bernie at one percent so uh I would not
buy AOC at that Mark I would buy Biden
like crazy though I'm not a Gambling Man
but I would I would totally toss a toss
a g at Biden at that amount I always say
1.5 chance I think it's I think it's I
don't think she runs
um you don't think she runs yeah okay I
don't think Bernie will primary Biden
either I mean he Eddie Biden doesn't run
then obviously it's an open field